a fiery exchange between the former
Chancellor of the exchequer and the
covid inquiry lawyer if someone had said
it was George Osborne's turn today to
defend his work and not just defend he
took credit for helping us survive the
pandemic
from the furlough scheme to avoiding a
banking crisis to funding the vaccine
program
in 2020 it turned out to be fairly easy
and Rapid to be able to put those
support systems in place through the
program we pursued as a government we
created the fiscal space so we could end
up spending 370 billion pounds to help
people deal with all the adverse effects
that the lockdown introduced if Mr
Osborne was looking for a thank you this
isn't the place the covid inquiry is
trying to establish whether his treasury
had planned for a pandemic their witness
today told them in no uncertain terms it
hadn't
no one I'm aware of anywhere in the
Western World maybe anywhere else
anywhere in the world said you know what
governments should prepare for they
should prepare for a conversed pandemic
that will require us to lock down the
entire economy for months on end
obviously if someone had said that
then there would be a legitimate
question which is why are you preparing
for it but I'm unfortunately no one did
like his boss the day before Mr Osborne
left the inquiry refusing to accept any
blame he'd been forced to defend his
austerity regime because earlier this
week there'd been suggestions that he
and David Cameron had left the Health
Service depleted that came from the
doctors Union the trades Union Congress
and some bereaved family members
now it's up to the inquiry chair to say
whether she agrees Saudia Chaudhary Sky
News at the covet inquiry in London